I just adopted her about five days ago
and she's ten years old we have our
instant carpet for your little dog I
should probably pee on it that's what is
the most used emoji on your phone
probably the one that has the teeth
really big and they're like like that
one works for everything I just like the
teeth or the like like I'm being naughty
I'm being cheeky I mean so many things
with the most used app snapchat at the
moment so fun it's either snapchat or
uber or the Domino's ad for uber uber is
a good one that is not used as much
because they work Monday through Friday
but on the weekend they'll use it
periodically it was the last person you
texted my sister she actually FaceTime
me and then I text her saying sorry I
can't take time right now I'm at Comic
Con and what is an album or song people
will be surprised to know as on your
fall rolling stone really you're a rock
and roll chick I love it all right we'll
have fun out there today thanks for
stopping by the instacart weird